haven't done the research which I ended
up doing the research kind of on
accident I was an egalitarian but I was
fed up with female behavior and I would
confide to my fiance about the things
that I was frustrated with or that women
are capable of malice because I'd been
primarily bullied by women my whole life
and so he ends up like putting me on
this red pill you know the the
documentary and it basically lays out
that women are just as capable as
aggression as as men but um really I
didn't know that
yeah we just do it differently yeah okay
now tell me but I haven't seen the
documentary okay okay so if you look up
the FBI statistics on DV it's almost 50
50 like men and women okay right so
women have a tendency to slap more
though versus like physical assault that
was something I read in a social
psychology textbook but also women's
typical choice of aggression is indirect
aggression so it's uh attacking
somebody's character or their okay what
is it when people have esteem for you
what is that called I can't it's coming
out of my brain right now like
characters reputation okay yeah yeah
okay yeah so that's that's indirect
aggression and that's why you'll see
like some women do you know false
accusations about certain things but
women are just as aggressive as as men
and then when you look at the statistics
for child a b u s e women are doing it
too so that was one thing that really
woke me up that women do have some
negative aspects to them but it's not
it's not that female nature is good or
bad it's just human nature is what it is
and we're all capable of violence so
that was more so what I was trying to
figure out is you know what's wrong with
me that I can't maintain female
friendships and come to find out that I
think there's quite a there's a lot more
pathological women than we really know
is the conclusion that I came to
um
but I wanted to say that when people
look at my relationship and they see the
age gaps they literally think it is the
Pinnacle of the red pill experience
you're like oh my God he got a younger
woman he's 50. he has money uh and that
is such a unicorn fantasy and I'm 27 now
but you know one day I'm going to be 37
like these looks only last for so long
mm-hmm no and that's
it's not about the money we've said it
before and again it is not about the
money alone it is about the character
that is like built in order to acquire
money I would say
um unless you're a straight up gold
digger which I can very much tell you or
not so
um
steal this dudes re who knows catch me
on the news really quick really quick uh
ladies thank you for telling the nude
truth I found you two on Donovan and I'm
glad I did keep telling the hard truths
thank you so much for the donation all
donations go towards new mics for um and
a new soundboard so I can host eight
girls in my living room for a podcast
that we're gonna do weekly or supposed
to be today sadly there was a storm so
next week we're gonna we're gonna
do it but thank you ninja Watcher for
life okay sorry
no I I'm all about
yeah I know when we when we get to talk
and we just
I also don't want to overtalk you on
your own platform and make sure you say
stuff oh no I am that's like when I
invite people I want you guys to talk
you openly say you are hypergamous
yeah like what's wrong with it what what
I'm supposed to do be with a dude that
makes forty thousand dollars a year and
raise my three kids like with what I
need like
well I think everyone even men too they
everyone wants to get the best mate they
can like on both ends like I don't think
anyone's saying I hope I can find
someone that I can do better than I
think men are just the problem is when
it gets unrealistic and I think that's
where men get mad when women like don't
settle won't compromise but
I don't see anything wrong with wanting
to be with the best like fit for you
right so hypergamy gets a bad reputation
because women right now we have
unfettered hypergamy like the we like
stuff you don't think hypergamy is real
do me a favor after the live stream go
to the mall look around I want you to
count as many female humans that you see
I want your cat as many male humans as
you see tell me when you're out here
shopping it's true go to Goodwill go to
Ross it's full of chicks so we we just
like stuff is my my perspective on it
and also it for the women that don't
think that hypergamy is real How come
every time one of your home girls
graduates from law school or medical
school the first thing they buy is a
Gucci bag or some Louboutins like
it's very obvious for hypergamous uh
it's such a waste of money too I could
you will not catch me you will not catch
me buying oh no you will not catch me
buying that
it's it's a lot of fun too because I was
hanging out with my grandma
uh last week which a couple days ago and
we were out shopping and she's literally
trying to buy her 11th perfume and she
doesn't need it and she's just grabbing
the stuff off they're like oh this is so
cute and it's it's female nature in
action hypergamy isn't bad it's just
it's it can get you burned and that's
why I say women don't settle with men
because that is disingenuous to the
value of men really what you do is you
take a deal and you take a deal that
makes sense the man offers you his
resources you offer him this in return
you make an agreement you abide by the
agreement and everything's good in
kosher the reason why women are
hypergamous you already know some a lot
of this stuff but I guess maybe your
audience might not know is uh we have a
globalized dating Market if I wanted to
want right now I could find a
millionaire across the world who would
fly me out the thing is is that the same
guy that's going to commit to me so
let's say
I lose my hypergamous mind and I just
leave my man for another man who makes
way more money maybe exactly that stupid
game because it's dumb the the man that
I'm running into who I guess we would
say like hot high value or something he
is going to know that I'm a woman and
incapable of commitment and capable of
judgment so he's probably not going to
reproduce with me he probably most
likely will not marry me
right so you just have to know when to
take a deal with someone and we were
saying earlier that it's not necessarily
about the money so my man could lose his
job but I'm not worried because I'm very
confident that within 30 days he would
find some other form of gainful
employment and we can downsize right I'm
not expecting him to become this
homeless heroin addict overnight or
something it's just let's just keep it
normal
oh no it's it's the same thing my dad he
right before in 2007 2006 he bought a
neighborhood with their life savings
and then the housing market crashed so
they put everything all of the money
they'd made and they were not as like
well off as they are like now back then
like their business wasn't even doing
close to as good and like my mom didn't
leave him because he was you know I
don't want to say he was broke because
we still lived in the same house but
like we were very close to losing
everything and
um like men value loyalty like they want
someone that's gonna stick with them
through thick and thin
yo it's crazy it's crazy what a man will
put up with for some loyalty like you
know my relationship looks really good
on the internet but I'm still a woman
I'm still emotional and I'm telling you
sometimes the way I just be absolutely
in my feelings crying on the couch over
something small like I'm a loser you
know and he's just sitting there taking
it saying it's okay it's all right I
can't do that at work ain't no manager
or supervisor gonna hold me down but a
man will sit there and listen to your
crazy rant for 30 minutes just because
you're there you're solid about nothing
about math
about everything
I saw this commercial that just it was
the kid like